I already got it on my pant
these pants are destroyed welcome to
everyday I'm day yeah hohoho this is
cheers to you
where I've been drinking since December
3rd but openly starting right now so I'm
kicking off my first round of the
weekend by cheering all the people and
traditions that encouraged me to drink
[Music]
cheers to you chocolate advent calendars
helping Americans countdown to type-2
diabetes
I'm not far behind cheers to you
principal that band candy canes for
claiming they're shaped like J for Jesus
that's probably not true but then again
neither is the story of Jesus I think
that principle was boy if the J does
stand for Jesus we can't have a bunch of
kids just sucking him off cheers to you
December 26 for being the day people
return gifts to see exactly how much
their family loves them last year I
found out my mom loved me a hundred and
five dollars less than the year before
and honestly that's generous
Cheers do eggnog for being disgusting
but helping my father slow down his
alcohol consumption and probably several
arteries eggnog is mostly bourbon heavy
cream and eggs which happens to be the
same ingredients as an abortion jairs do
Christmas trees but every year just so
grandparents aren't the only ones
actively dying in the living room that
cleanup is so bad to see a mistletoe for
being one sneaky son of a bitch and
forcing me to make out with my cousin
some say that's disgusting but hey rules
are rules
and I am from Virginia cheers to you
Christmas lights for brightening up
homes and being a festive way for
families to say hey we're not Jewish
cheers to all you boyfriends who give
really shitty Christmas gifts you can
take that 60% off Macy's robe and shove
it right up the hole in my heart because
I am alone and cold and will take
anything at this point thanks for
watching every day thanks for watching
oh like I'll be here all week I'm still
going baby for Christmas I'm giving you
more me this is Christmas attention axe
why have a conversation with your
relatives when you can be the
conversation for your relatives these
are tips I've done I've seen you're
welcome shout your prayers if you're
dragged to church by your sin riddled
relatives it's been the experience and
no positive you probably did a lot of
damage this year with the man upstairs
and many men down below this is your
time to confess your sins loud and proud
dear God let that be a Sun rash even
though it is wintertime and that part of
my body has never seen the Sun maybe God
will cure you or at the very least
you'll spice up that boring bread part
that happens in church next grow one
long now
some people might assume you have a
cocaine problem but in order to have a
cocaine problem you have to be rich so
take it as a compliment this nail gives
you the allure of wealth and it's also a
great way to steal food off other
people's plates love sweet potatoes fake
a dead boyfriend print out a stock photo
of an average-looking male you don't
want it to be obvious that you're lying
so when relatives ask you why you're
single you can say your boyfriend died
on a jet ski
they'll think you date someone
successful and fun and they'll feel bad
for you next
never sit down with the amount of
parties and Family Affairs happening
it's easy for those drunk weary bones to
get tired but never sit establish
dominance in room by rising above
everyone literally what is the generous
act to some is a power move for you
punish your relatives regardless of what
religion you are puns bring people
closer by creating a shared sense of
discomfort feel free to use these
gentlemen I came empty-handed but I
definitely brought the biggest package
damn just only 14 years old but she for
sure's the Nutcracker in the room mmm
mmm girl I'd love to suck on those
mistletoes and finally stay close to the
ones you love and by that I definitely
don't mean family when it comes time to
scouting your New Year's kiss proximity
is key you officially have one week
until the ball drops we need to scout
your target and remain close you don't
want that ball to be the only thing
going down so have fun stay safe but
take risks be sure to LIKE comment and
subscribe